uh very good morning to you
i bet yeah how are you i'm i'm very well
but i'm also slightly embarrassed i have
to say i've been a fan of yours since
from the festive fun days rahul is
depart up the road from where we are at
the moment i did not know that you
yourself had suffered um from testicular
cancer and i was shocked to read that
when i was reading up on this this
morning tell us a little bit about your
experience
yeah well it just all happened last year
and it sort of came out nowhere i'm i'm
actually a little bit older than that
than most people who get this i was 53 i
think when i got it and um
i just noticed uh one of my testicles
was feeling a bit heavier and a bit
stranger than usual and um
as most men do i kind of left it for a
bit thinking you know feeling it was a
bit embarrassing and uh eventually i
kind of thought i'll just go and get it
checked out and uh
yeah it was it was quite a long process
my doctor didn't think it was going to
be cancer but they'd take you and give
you a scan anyway and there's lots of
things it can be if you've got anything
unusual happening down there so if
anything you do have anything just go
straight to your gp and they will check
you out they scanned me they found
something in there didn't know what it
was but they decided they had to take it
out
and once they'd taken it out they
discovered it was uh it was cancer so
it's it it's you know it's it was a it
was a weird thing to happen and it was a
it um
you know it took me by surprise i wasn't
i wasn't no one's had cancer in my
family and you know and uh
i didn't i sort of didn't think anything
like this would happen to me i've even
done testicular cancer campaigns in the
past
um and uh yeah so but but
it's actually so treatable i mean you
know the treatment often is to to remove
the testicle but
if it's done before it spreads
um yeah you know it's it's 99 of people
uh survive this cancer so it's it's um
it's so if you're going to get cancer
it's not a bad one to get but also
you've got no totally
yeah can um
can
help themselves by checking themselves
just regularly and and uh any anything
that's an unusual give it then but yeah
just just on that richard i mean
given that traditionally you know men
have generally spent quite a lot of time
in that region i mean i'm just wondering
why we're so bad at doing the checks
that you know you you yourself did that
led to finding out you had testicular
cancer yeah i think i know i'm still
almost the same now even after i've had
it it's just something weird about the
male psyche and we have to overcome it
as a comedian i talk about subjects and
i've talked about these subjects a lot
so it's sort of funny that uh this sort
of thing this has happened to me in or
ironically this has happened to me uh
and i've always been encouraging men to
talk about things i think we sort of
tried to man up or we think it's there's
some sort of sort of weakness and going
to the doctor or i was feeling you know
kovid was rife at the time and i didn't
want to waste
the nhs his time with something like
this so you know there's loads of
excuses you can make and it's
embarrassing and i think with your
testicles
you know they're so
associated with manliness which is crazy
when you think about it you know
that
you're meant to be tough or strong
because they're the weakest part of the
human body and a man can be felt by a
toddler if a toddler runs into them so
you know it's it's weird that we
associate with manliness but i think men
just have to overcome this embarrassment
and and i talk and
how has the comedy helped you with this
which i mean has it i mean i understand
that you've got your new book uh can i
have my ball back uh which i think you
can understand the title there i mean
has the humor actually managed to help
you yeah definitely i think with
everything i think being able to laugh
at it is a great thing and being able to
talk about it and i think i was very
open about it
on twitter almost straight away and
that's very helpful to other people but
i think you know it there's a lot of
funny stuff and the book is a very funny
book um money there's you know there was
there's obviously some moments of
concern and worry as well but i think i
think by looking at a serious subject in
a comedic way hey
you know you're laughing in the face of
cancer which is not not a bad thing i
think that's the only power we have
against many cancers
and uh and you know i think it just
having a positive attitude that it made
me really reassess everything i kind of
you know for a moment i thought oh my
goodness you know i'm going to die
and i've got young kids and so it was
very worrying but it you know you get
your priorities right but i think by
being able to laugh at it and and you
know people who do still find it funny
you know that strangers on twitter will
will make jokes about it straight away
and i don't mind at all because i think
that's fine and you know if you don't
want to laugh about it that's also fine
but i think having a positive really
helps
richard i i just remember the the the
line from uh that american comedy veep
check him don't neglect him
it sums it up well um richard herring
thank you so much and thanks for all the
laughs over the years you've provided me
with plenty i really appreciate it